bringing elbows going on lay here and
I'm here with where did you go somebody
comes you see why we didn't answer damn
Berlin England that's awesome how much
fans over there I'm actually amazing
yeah amazing
why are you expecting them to be just
all like dieter chocolate in France in a
gas station ahead cognac in it like
shots of cognac just drink yeah
you know you just buy cognac without
chocolate it's nicer on it just in a
bottle
I just one thing you guys are no pork in
your in your live shows is you guys do a
lot of face paint a lot of makeup yeah
well where did that come from
it originated during the Anna Sun so
that's gonna work I'll start it yeah
yeah and you guys were like let's just
continue this trend
yeah it just was so much fun and people
really responded to it and then they
started coming to shows in basements
yeah sort of bringing it I have a
confession I saw you guys I played
Grouplove last year at a satellite here
in that LA and by accident I stole your
face paint so I thought maybe you guys
could revenge paint me if you want it
first thing you have to do is connect
with your inner spirit animal
okay I'm empty inside I'm a shirt going
in for a kill there's nothing there all
right so I'm a shark that's my screwed
trail now you just
you're thinking about the technique
you're thinking about it too much oh
there we go all right I'm just gonna
present some powers that I can just tell
now is this a bad time to mention I have
a skin rash if you need a bigger canvas
just that's the only time four dudes
have worked on another dudes face
without it you know we're not making a
German video somehow this is amazing I
really a hairy man I feel redeemed I
feel her game guys walk the moon thank
you so much pick up their album walk the
moon and walk the moon been calm for two
days
[Music]